and welcome back we are now on number
seven
number seven on page 409
dwayne
has a newspaper route for which he
collects k dollars per day he collects k
k
dollars
per day
that's how much dwayne collects
from this amount he pays out
so he pays out this is how much he makes
he pays out k
over 3
dollars per day
for the cost of the paper so this is
cost
of papers
and he saves the rest of the money
in terms of k
how many days will it take duane
to save 1 000
that's his goal
well how much does he make per day
well he makes k and he has to give out k
over three so
per day so each day per day
per day
he makes k
minus k over three
we could make this you know we could
write this as
three k
minus k over 3 right i just
this is this is k is the same thing as 3
k over 3 right so this is equal to 2 k
over 3 right that's how much he makes
per day
so how much does he make in d days and
you know in 10 days how much if d is the
number of days how much does he make
well he makes
2 k
over 3 times d that's how much he makes
right in d days
well
he wants to make a thousand dollars so
he wants to make a thousand dollars
so how many days is it going to take
well this is
uh hopefully
a love you you realize it's a level one
linear equation
so we multiply both sides times the
reciprocal so 3 over 2k
times this
times 3 over 2k
all right this cancels this this cancels
that cancels you just look for the d on
the left hand side and on the right hand
side we could do a little canceling too
this 2
will cancel and make this into a 500
you have 500 times 3 over k so that
equals i don't know why i started
tilting that equals
fifteen
hundred
over
fifteen hundred over
k
days
and that is choice number d
all right i get excited number eight it
has a number line i get excited whenever
there's a number line problem
i don't know why it's
psychological disorder perhaps
but a good one some you know some
abnormalities or positive abnormalities
let's see so let me draw this this
number line
all right i drew that number line
it's a number line
and most of the time it's probably just
going to take drawing it let's see so i
have let me do this in a different color
so i have point a you do a more vivid
color point a
is here and then it's right next to
negative two it's a little bit less than
negative two which is right there
then i have
negative one right here
negative 1 then i got a bunch of points
i have
b
p
i have
c
then i have a 0
then i have one
and then i have
a couple of points more
d
and then i have
q
then i have the number two
and i have e
all right so let's read the problem
which of the letter points on the number
line above could represent the result
when the coordinate of point p is
multiplied by the coordinate of point
q all right so this is
pretty much just an approximation
problem right so we're trying to figure
out you know p times q essentially so
point p well look that's uh looks
eyeball it it's a little bit to the left
of zero to the right of negative one
looks like maybe i don't know i'm just
guessing minus point five minus one half
right minus one half
and what's q
well q is
looks uh
a little bit you know maybe closer to
two than it is to one so i would say
maybe
one and three-fourths i'm just guessing
you know you could just approximate it
as you want so one and three-fourths
so this is one and three-fourths or if
you wanted to write that as an improper
fraction which i prefer to deal with
seven-fourths right i'm just eyeballing
it nothing fancy here
so if p is one minus one-half and this
number is seven-fourths
so what is what happens when you
multiply the two so minus one half
times
seven fourths
is equal to
minus seven
over eight right so minus seven over
eight that's a little bit to the that's
a lit it's almost minus 8 over 8 right
minus 8 over 8 would be
would be here
right
minus 8 over 8 would be at my negative
1. and so this is a little less negative
or it's so it's a slightly larger number
so minus 7 array is going to be
someplace around this area well it's
interesting that i've bumped into a
number there while i was looking at that
area i bumped into point b
and you know it made my approximations
wrong maybe it could be point c a point
p when i look at the choices p isn't a
choice and only b is so b is what i
would bubble in
as what the uh
what what happens when you multiply p
times q and that that was kind of fun
because it's just pure approximation and
you kind of get something that
approaches the answer oh it is the
answer i guess hopefully
all right
i'm having too much fun
absolutely too much fun okay if number
nine
if 5
y
plus 2 x
is equal to 23
and x is equal to y plus one
what is the value of y what does y equal
well this we can do straight up
substitution to solve we have x is equal
to y plus one substitute
substitute for x so then we're left with
y
plus
2 times x for x we substitute this term
2 times y plus 1 is equal to 23 we just
do algebra or even arithmetic
5y plus distribute the 2 2y plus 2 is
equal to 23.
5y plus 2y is 7y
plus 2 is equal to 23.
subtract 2 from both sides 7y is equal
to 21.
y is equal to 3. they're just this this
this was just a question to see if you
even took algebra 1.
not not to make you feel bad if you
don't remember people forget things but
anyway
let's move on number 10.
a company produced 300 appliances in the
first week of the month
so this is number 10 we're doing let me
switch colors
move is too dark so week one so let's
say week
one
appliances
produced 500 in week one
and the first we could because it
received additional machinery its
production increased 50 percent from the
first week to the second week how many
appliances did the company produce in
the second week i didn't even have to
make a table here right so it improved
fifty percent so plus fifty percent
so it's important it improved fifty
percent week two isn't fifty percent of
five hundred it's 50
more than 500 right so it's 500
plus 50 percent of 500
and what's 50 of 500
well that's 250 right so it's 250 plus
500 is 750.
that was i was looking forward to
something more challenging
anyway
number 11 let's see if i have time to do
number 11 in this video if i can
each angle if the length of the side
what is one possible you know what i
only have one minute left i will do this
in the next video see you soon